Ethan: "Do I need any weird audio stuff on discord?"
Wade: "Oh, you need dildo sound effects, that's it."
Ethan: "No that's not what I mean..."
Mark: "Dildo sound effects"
Bob: *Dildo sound effects*
Ethan: Because i'm just going to use the game audio, correct?
Mark: Yes...
Bob: It really hurts my face to do that.
Mark: Why are you doing that? Do-don't do that.
Bob: You said dildo sound effects...
Mark: Private match, what we want to do? Blood and gold or Megalodon hunt?
Ethan: Megalodon hunt!!
Mark: Okay...
Ethan: That sounds cool!
Mark: No bots or yes bots?
Mark: Let's - let's just do us, lets see how this goes.  I don't know how this is gonna go but maybe it's going to go so let's find a little private server.
Wade: I think Megalodon hunt is one of us is a megalodon or..
Mark: Yeah, no, that's how it goes, one person become the megalodon,
Wade: It's going to be very difficult for the divers
Mark: I've never played it but one person is the
Mark: Megalodon we have to kill it and become the Megalodon
Bob: Yeah it's basically shark
juggernaut right? (Mark: Yeaah) Ethan: Well I want to be
the Megalodon. (Mark: Well you--) This already looks scary as fuck
Mark: I KNOW, RIGHT?! God, I hate the ocean!
Ethan: I don't-- like, it's just dark
black water.
Wade:Hey guys welcome to Depth.
(laughter)
Mark: This isn't a gun! What is this?
Ethan: Wait. Oh wait.
Wade: This is a weapon!
Bob: This is our faster device.
Ethan: Wait none of us are the Megalodon.
Mark: Oh that's not good.
Ethan: Wait (Bob: OH) so somebody-- Oh noo.
Mark: Oh nooo. (chuckling)
Ethan: So maybe we have to kill the Megalodon first and
then whoever- oh there he is.
Mark: Oh that's a big boy
Oh that's a big boy!
Wade: Wait, is it just sitting still?
Mark: Yeah?
Ethan: No, I think it's coming towards us.
Bob: Is it uncontrolled?
Bob: No it's not swimming- oh it is swimming.
Mark: I'm shooting it-- Oh my god I'm going for it.
Wade: I don't think its swimming.
Mark: Guys I'm going for it.
Bob: I'm going for it too.
Bob: It's just floating- what? What is this?
Ethan: I don't know where I am, I'm in a tunnel.
Mark: Hey! who took the-
Bob: Oh I stole your kill!
Mark: What the fuck?!
Ethan: You're now the Megalodon?
Mark: What? Oh!
Ethan: You already killed it?
Mark: Oooohhh. So one of us just had to be the Megalodon
Wade: Oh hey look, some treasure we can't gather.
Mark: Yeah we can.
Wade: We picked the wrong game mode.
Mark: Yea-- Yea, no, you can gather it.
Mark: Whoaoaoaoaoaoaoao
Wade *screaming*
Bob: Hey friends.
Mark: OH GOD!
Wade: *continues screaming*
Bob: Hey friends!!
Wade: No Bob not me!!
Mark: Oh God! (screaming) Kill him! Holy fucking shit!
Bob: Am I murdering you sufficiently?
Ethan: THIS IS-- HORRIFYING!
Bob: DOUBLE KILL!
Ethan: OH NOOO! I don't even want to try and kill the shark I just
want to fucking hide. (Heavy breathing) (same Ethan, same.)
Mark: Whoa. Okay.
Ethan: Hey there!! How's it going?!
Bob: You need to hide better I think.
Ethan: *high pitched screaming and laughing*
Ethan: It's just my bloody corpse floating in the water! (Mark laughing)
Bob: Oh shit! Oh god I didn't realize that was my health.. Awww.
Mark: Wait, who became-- Who became the Megaladon? Bob: Wade.
Mark: Noooo Wade. Bob: Wade did I think. Mark: Wade don't do it.
Ethan: I definitely didn't. I just got--
Wade: Who's hitting me already? I just spawned in.
Mark: No one-- No one is hitting you. You just be quiet you.
Bob: OH GOD OH FOR FUCK'S SAKE!
Mark: Oh fuck!
Bob: OH NO!!.. Goddamnit.
Ethan: Bob, are you okay? Hehe.
Bob: Mm, I'm fine.
Ethan: oooh OOH OOOOOOOOOH OHNO OH NO OH NO! HA YOU MISSED!
Mark: Don't worry
Wade: Awww.
Ethan: I damaged you.
Mark: Waaahh! Oh! Yay! I did it! I did it! I am the shark noooow!
Wade: I spawned a lot closer than I thought
(Talking over each other)
Ethan: -- to be a shark up on the streets.
Bob: So where-- Can we see where he is? Or--
Wade: Yeah, it's like a red glow
Mark: Well that's not fair.
Bob: Well yeah-
Wade: I know it's not! That's why when I spawned in being shot at
I was already bitter.
Bob: Oh my god I got double pistols now, mother fucker.
Mark: I see you. I see you. I see you! Whoa! (Ethan noises)
Ethan: Oh my god! Oh my god no! Dammit!
Bob: Ethan, distract him!
Ethan: I did some good distracting. Mark: Who's shooting me?
Mark: Ah!
Ethan: Looking at your corpse after you get-Others yell
Bob: Die mother fucker!
Mark: Noo!
Bob: Oh I was so close.
Mark: Noo.
Bob: Now someone else is gonna kill him.
Bob: I had two guns and everything. Do I keep it? Oh I do keep it.
Mark: Ah! Who's doing that? I'm gonna eat some seals. (Mark shark noises)
Mark: AAAHHH! Who's doing that?
Mark: Whoa
Mark: Ow! Fuck.
Wade: HAHA
Bob: Aw.
Mark: I was just eating--
Mark: I was eating seals being a nice little megalodon
Mark: and you guys, you guys are assholes.
Ethan: A nice little, giant man-eating shark.
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: You know, you know..
Wade: He was, he was being a nice little guy.
Bob: Come at me motherfucker
Mark: *in accent* Come at me meother-fuucker
Wade: Wait, is that my; is your health that little pizza pie?
Mark: Uhh..
Bob: That thing thats going down,
Bob: Thats your health.
Ethan: Your health is measured in pizzas *laughs*
Ethan, Mark, Bob: *laughter*
Bob: Are they... Are you sure its not cherry pies?
Mark: *continues laughing*
Wade: I hate you.
Ethan: OH NO!
Mark: WHoaaa
Ethan: No god dammit. *sighs*
Ethan: Oh nooo. My body is stuck between the rocks.
Bob: Is there a way for us to buy gear or something?
Mark: Yeah you, the more treasure you gather, the more uh gear your get upgraded-did-dids...
Mark: That made sense.
Bob: Where do we, where do we upgrade it though?
Mark: It automatically happens when you re-spawn I think
Mark: Cuz I have a better gun and I do not recall ever...
Bob: Oh yeah it automatically happens, I just got guns without even dying.
Mark: Nice.
Ethan: Ohh fuck. God dammit. Its just so hard to kill you.
Mark: *laughs* Fack.
Mark: No its not..
Wade: Yuup.
Mark: You just gotta get good son.
Ethan: Get good. Gotta no-scope em
Bob: Gotta giggity good.
Mark: Get good shit hole.
Mark: WHOAH, whoa fuck. *screams*
Wade: Ah haa!
Mark: Ohh I almost had you.
Wade: Rammed you
Mark: I almost had you!
Bob: Oh my god I have a sub-machine gun.
Bob: Prepare to get fucked Wade.
Ethan: Ohhh! I am the mega-lo-doooon!
Ethan: Hey there
Mark: You better not kill me I'm just gathering, I'm just gathering gold
Ethan: *whispering* Wait, I dont know.. where are you??
Ethan: *monster voice* Where are you?
Mark: WHERE ARE YAAA *laughs*
Wade: We are the silence in the--
Ethan: OH I CAN SEE MY DEAD SHARK FRIENDS..
Ethan: Just floating here. My ancestors.. GODDAMMIT! Where are you?!
Ethan: You're so small!!
Ethan: AHHH I see you--
Bob: SEE YA!!
Bob: Gotta go bye!!
Bob: *giggles*
Ethan: Gotta go faaast!
Mark: Gottagofast!
Bob: See ya
Ethan: Oh god dammit
Bob: Nooooo god, awh jeeze!
Ethan: I am bad at being shark!
Wade: *laughs*
Ethan: Where did you go, where did you goo
Bob: No where! I'm no where
Ethan: Look theres a seal!
Bob: This is fine.
Ethan: Hey there buuud. Ah Hahaha I got it! I gotta thrash em!
Ethan: Ouch ouch don't do that, hey! I just want to--
Mark: noOOOO! *Everyone talks excitedly*
Bob: Who just took my fucking kill?! You bitch!
Mark: I took it biitch! I took it beeiitchh!
Ethan: I was so excited to be the shark and it was so short lived.
Mark: Ow, who did that, who is doing?
Bob: Fuck.
Bob: Fuck you motherfucker
Mark: Ooo I see who doing
Bob: Nope see ya! Gotta go gotta go fast! Bye see ya!
Mark: It is you! Is it youu! Is it youu big boooy?
Bob: It wasn't me! It wasn't me!
Mark: I think its youu buddy booy!
Bob: Nope! No! Fuck! Oh god
Mark: AGH! *laughs*
Ethan: *laughs*
Bob: Man that totally worked before--
Mark: Hello friend AAHHHHHH--
Ethan: Oh oh oh oh
Bob: I lost Ethan before
Wade: Stabby stabby!
Ethan: Oh, ohh, ooOOhoho!
Mark: *giggles*
*everyone laughing and yelling*
Bob: Ohhh man
Ethan: This is so difficult!
Mark: *in accent* Ohhh yes please I like tha blood
Ethan: Ohhh my poor body.
Bob: Mark is going to SUCK at-at this game.
Wade: He has been playing it recently.
Mark: I've just been playing for like an hour
Mark: maybe but you know I've never been the shark before so *laughs*
Mark: Maybe you guys just are balls ass
Wade: Wow. I mean you're right, but wow!
Mark: I see youuuu!
Ethan: God fucking god!
Mark: Ah who shoot?!
Ethan: I think I've died, more than anyone else!
Bob: Where is he, Wade, where is he?
Mark: *triumphant laugh*
Wade: *screams*
Mark: Awwhh *laughs*
Bob: Don't worry I'll save you
Bob: Aw crap
Ethan: Hey there
Bob: Where the fuck are you?
Mark: Whoa jeeze
Ethan: Here fishy fishy
Bob: Oh hey buddy
Mark: WhaAhaaahAh
Bob: Hey friend-
Bob: Hey friend!
Mark: No! NO!
Mark: AHHHHH!
Wade: Wait Bob's the..? When did Mark die?
Mark: Yeah-
Bob: I killed Mark.
Mark: Bob killed me after he killed all you guys
Mark: You know; Saving you.
Wade: That explains why the shark was back at full health, I was very upset
Bob: I'm not doing anything. Just leave me alone.
Wade: Stop getting seals!!
Bob: I'm just your friendly neighborhood Megalodon! This is fine.
Ethan: *chuckles* Your friendly neighborhood Megalodon
Mark: Oh.
Bob: Would you fucking stop it?
Ethan: How's that- *accent* How's that feel huh?? *drops accent* Where'd you go, oh no
Wade: *giggles*
Mark: *in accent* How's that feel for youu
Ethan: Oh ohhh noo, your fins!
Bob: Hey buddy!
Mark: WHOOOAAA what that FUCK!
Ethan: God dammit
Mark, Wade: *both yelling*
Bob: Oh my god!
Wade: WHAT!
Bob: You have an exploding thing
Mark: Yuup!
Bob: What the fuck?!
Mark: Yeah I do!
Ethan: I got an assisted kill
Mark: *in accent* You diiid it
Wade: Whaaat?!
Mark: WAAAH!!
Wade: *screams*
Mark: Fucking wah *giggles*
Wade: Whooaa!!!
*Wade screaming while everyone else laughs*
Mark: YEAAHH!!!
Bob: Whoa nooo!!
*everyone talking at once*
Bob: I was so close!!
Mark: *celebrating loudly*
Ethan: I got laaast.
Mark: HA haaa!
Ethan: I got last by a lot
Mark: *still celebrating*
Bob: God dammit
Ethan: I didn't even kill one person when I was the shark
Bob:*whispering* Ethan you suck.
Mark: Wow you didn't. Wow you really didn't.
Ethan: Terrible! Terrible
Mark: Ohh boy.
Wade: Its okay, it's really hard to kill people as an overpowered Megalodon
*everyone laughs*
Bob: As an infinitely powerful shark that can swim much faster than everyone else in the game
Bob: It's tough you know
Mark: *laughing loudly*
Ethan: It is tough; It's really tough.
*Outro music*